Did you see the video about the guy? He almost threw up in his mouth and a,
I did it on the age three. We talked about it on H three.
The gun was throw up in his mouth. Dude. When you almost throw up in your mouth,
this guy, I don't know. It's like a Swedish Swedish,
um, throw up in mouth. See if I can find it.
We talked about an H three, a video.
Was it Swedish? Even? I don't even know. Oh, here it is. Here it is. Finished.
Pallet finish, finished politician, vomit vomits in his own mouth.
I taught, we talked about on eighth street, but we'll do it here too.
[inaudible] Oh, like I so nervous, dude. Have you seen this?
[inaudible] and Dale [inaudible]
[inaudible] um, you mentioned
Mark eight seconds. Seven, seven sections.
And there it is. [inaudible] no,
I want that guy to be my father. Do you understand if you're, first of all,
he had four minutes to talk and he was nervous the whole
time and in the final five seconds, he, his body was like, you know what?
it. And it came up and he goes like, uh, like, uh,
like someone who can not Rudo run, like, like a J J Japan animation,
like horrible. And then he just goes, no, you're not, Oh, Hey, throw up.
I'm in charge of my body. My mouth doesn't open. If I don't say it does.
And then swallows it back up and, and, and re,
and the remaining second text by that guy. Hey guy,
congratulations.
I'm related to you because I wa I am I,
or I should say you're related to me. Thank you for that, because that,
you're my you're partly in my top five heroes that's gangster.
I would open my mouth and thrown the up and w and I would have let it happen.
And I would have been like, that's what you get, man. That's what happens,
you know? Uh,
but this guy finished politician vomits in his own mouth during an interview,
swallows it and continues talking. Do you understand
somebody writes true warrior under it.
Wow. That's amazing. Vomit.
Look at these top five puking fails. Let's look at these.
I mean, you don't need to grab it for it. You know, it's just show the videos.
Top five puking Koscot graphic.
Oh, wow. Dude, I'm going to send this to you. Oh,
wow. Dude. I mean that, one's hilarious.
This guy is in a parking lot,
throws up and someone walking by an older lady walking by just falls
down because of it like straight up. Doesn't even,
I just sent, emailed it to you. You have it. You have it. I mean,
she just falls the down, dude, with our bags. When you fall down with bags,
that's it. That's how the girl looked in my high school that fell down.
It was to run away and she's holding her granddaughter's hand.
Okay. Now we got a little girl. Wow. I love that.
That was like at a grocery store parking lot.
Now we've got a little girl in like a wizard hat and she's doing a play or
something.
She's cute.
Oh. And she just threw the up. Like it was part of the play.
Oh, she's killing it. Wow. That's not. How did that come?
Did they siphon that through her? How did she get that much in her? Wow.
That's amazing. Uh, these guys already deserve it.
I can tell this is the number three and these guys already deserve it.
And I can tell because these guys all straight up, I swear to God,
our li our Theo Von fans. You can tell one, guy's wearing a Louisville shirt,
another guy's wearing a wife beater,
and they're in a kitchen that you would be molested in a hundred percent.
And then another guy, I don't even know how to describe the other guy. He,
I mean, he just looked, he looks like he would be on every, any small,
any town where they were like,
and we're going live to the street to see what the deal is.
They'd be interviewing that guy. And there's a big, big, big,
big McDonald's cup on the thing don't ever get. The big, big, big meetup,
the McDonald's cup. That's too big. And then it, that,
that it has to get smaller. So it'll fit in cup holders. If you get that drink,
you're first to go get the out of life.
Get a drink that just fits in your cup holder.
Don't get one that has different sizes in it. What is it? A transformer.
[Inaudible].
Wow. He threw up on Theo bond.
You ever seen a Theo Von fan throw up on the Theo Von fan.
Look at that one right there. Here's a baby. And the lady is holding it up. Oh,
that's gonna throw up right on her face. And that's obvious. Good.
She deserves it. Oh, cute. Mommy. Ah, cute baby.
Aw, that's so cute, dude.
I want to have a son and have him throw up on me. Now, this guy is picking up a.
I mean, why are wheels so big? You know, [inaudible] this,
guy's got not only,
it's one thing to take the big tr truck wheel and toss it over as a workout
guy. You know what I mean?
And throw it over or take the mallet and smash it.
But this guy has got a whole apparatus
attached to the big wheel that you weight train with.
It says weight, training, cardio and fitness zone, full strong man facilities.
And this guy's got the apparatus in his hand and he's going to pick it up.
And my guess is he's going to upchuck all over the whole weight training
facility. Okay. Let's see.
And he pulled it down and it goes up again and it goes up again and down again.
Okay. Let a little bit of throw up out and then just kind of still okay.
And threw up again. And he's still going. Okay. Hey bud.
Okay. Okay. Oh, cool. Came out his nose. Oh, he's okay.
Okay. Well, wow. This guy's a monster, huh?
Oh my God. This guy, April,
once you start throwing up, stop. That's my whole motto.
Whatever I'm doing.
I mean, the guy kept going, Hey guy, stop. Hey,
all the doctors in the world stop that's them guy throws up nine
times while lifting up a tractor trailer, all doctors in the world stop.
Wow.
God.
That's amazing. I think they put a tarp down. Was that what that is?
Yeah. They put a tarp down in front of them.
Like maybe like this guy was the throb guy. Hey,
we got Tommy come and he's a throb guy.
So put the tarp down.
He's going to lift seven times this thing that nobody should lift seven times
and he's absolutely gonna throw up. So, but the top down,
cause he always starts up. We've got Tommy going. So it's all good.